[Music]
is that you Mario the new Super Mario
movie finally has a trailer but fans
just can't get over one major problem
Mama Mia the internet has been bracing
for the release of the teaser trailer
for The Super Mario Brothers movie which
stars Chris Pratt as everyone's favorite
Turtle stomping plumber fans have been
excited about the movie but not so much
about the prospect of pratts as the
voice of Mario with a trailer here the
consensus seems to be that the movie
looks and sounds great except for one
thing Everybody Hates Chris fans hopes
were not high leading up to the release
of the trailer with many predicting that
Chris Pratt's Midwestern voice would
sound silly coming out of Mario's mouth
gizmodo's James whitbrook for example
summed up the anticipation nicely
tweeting the second Chris Pratt Mario
opens his mouth in the trailer being on
Twitter is going to be a combination of
the day the queen died and the David
Katz trailer dropped Pratt defended his
performance before anyone heard it
telling variety that his voice for the
character would be unlike anything
you've heard in the Mario World before
well it may be unlike what anyone's
heard before but not necessarily in a
good way
what is this place
in response to the big reveal one fan
tweeted animation is beautiful and most
of the casting is perfect but still why
is Chris Pratt Mario similar sentiments
were expressed on Reddit including Jack
Black as Bowser sounded great Chris
Pratt sounds like Chris Pratt and not
Mario
Mushroom King
with a reaction to Pratt being so
negative could Universal and
illumination make some last minute
changes to the film it's not as
far-fetched as it might sound filmmakers
could arguably learn a lesson from
Mario's Sega counterparts when the
original trailer for Sonic the Hedgehog
was released fan responds to the
original Sonic design left many fans
disappointed to put it lightly the
film's director Jeff Fowler tweeted a
thank you for the fan support and for
the critique bound to make the changes
that fans asked for and thus Sonic was
redesigned which most fans seem to be
happy with in lonely Islands Chippendale
Rescue Rangers movie The Original
character designed for Sonic appears as
a character named ugly Sonic a fellow
dejected and rejected cartoon star who
could frequently be found working the
same convention circuit as Dale similar
fan reactions might have triggered a
redesign for She-Hulk after fans reacted
poorly to the design for the character
in the first trailer so there's
precedent for Universal Pictures to make
some tweaks to the movie especially with
the release date not being until April
7th of next year it's probably unlikely
that the studio would fire its lead
voice actor but they could possibly work
with him to try to find a voice that
sounds a little less like Chris Pratt
playing Chris Pratt meanwhile Pratt's
reputation is still reeling after an
Instagram post he made in November 2021
in which he wrote about his wife
Catherine Schwarzenegger she's given me
an amazing life a gorgeous healthy
daughter many fans took offense feeling
that this was a slight against his son
jack we had it with his first wife Anna
Faris as the child was born premature
and underweight in a recent interview
with Men's Health Pratt talked about how
hurt he was that people took offense to
what he intended as an innocent post my
son's going to read that one day he's
nine and it's etched in digital Stone it
really bothered me dude I cried about it
that's on top of his previous
controversy in the aftermath of his Late
Show with Stephen Colbert appearance
when Elliot page tweeted in 2019 that
Pratt's church was infamously anti-lgbtq
Pratt defended his church posting I go
to a church that opens their doors to
absolutely everyone so some resentment
against Pratt has been building online
over the last few years messing up the
Mario boys might be the start of a
full-on Chris Pratt backlash turtle
shell is in your court Universal